donc là vous avez le château c'est donc
la maison l'origine de deux points de
départ qui datent de grosso modo de la
fin du 19ème ensuite donc un
chronologiquement c'est le dojo c'est la
grave d'abord le grand dojo c'est
vraiment la maison principale
m deshimaru est le fondateur de ce
temple en 1979 après des années à
enseigner est pratiquée en occident ce
maître japonais du zen décide d'acquérir
le site de l'agent drones hier le grand
dojo est le premier bâtiment qui voit le
jour le dojo donc il a été conçu donc
pas remettre des schémas roues avec
l'aide de ses disciples architectes
avaient au moins 2 puis sinon il y avait
parmi ses disciples j'avais des chartons
un charpentier avait des menuisiers
avaient des plumes des plombiers des
électriciens
il y avait tous les corps de métiers
quasi un domaine exceptionnel géré par
les membres de l'association zen
international plus de 80 hectares
comprenant dépendance cuisine dortoir et
jardins potagers le tout pouvant
accueillir jusqu'à 3000 personnes
l'agent dremière est le plus grand
temple zen d'europe
sur une colline des stèles marque la
présence de tombes d'anciens disciples
la plus imposante et celle du maître
deshimaru pour ici oui à une symbolique
c'est que c'est un il ya un rituel tous
les matins et un rituel de gratitude où
on vient ici on vient le saluer et en
signe de gratitude pour le remercier de
nous avoir transmis une deuxième grande
célébration retraite ou cession de
pratique du zen intensifs l'agent
drenière accueille toute l'année des
pratiquants qu'ils soient débutants ou
confirmés
un domaine qu'il faut entretenir et
faire perdurer
je ne sais pas si c'est important la
chose c'est que il est là il y a il
existe c'est un peu voilà c'est
l'héritage de mettre des schémas rousse
et ses quelque chose c'est un gros truc
je sais pas si si il fallait ça en tout
cas on l'a et on sent et on fait avec on
fait tout pour que ça pour qu'il
s'épanouisse